un antiguo hospital psiquiátrico
construido hace más de 120 años en la
universidad Federal de Río de Janeiro a
la que solo le queda esta escalera de
madera de su pasado esplendor;
es una falta de mantenimiento que
representa un peligro permanente para
estudiantes como Jessica piñeiro que
estudia ciencias sociales
toda la universidad está hecha de madera
Así que si hay un incendio se acabó
porque no hay una salida de emergencia
no hay un protocolo de vacunación
desde el comienzo de la pandemia también
se han suspendido miles de becas de
estudio e investigación sin explicación
alguna al igual que esta universidad
otras 68 se encuentran en situación
preocupante en Brasil de 2019 al 2022 el
presupuesto de las universidades
públicas federales se ha recortado en un
50 por ciento
estos estudiantes han condenado al
fracaso las intenciones del gobierno de
privatizar su gestión instituciones
vistas como una amenaza por el gobierno
en las universidades han surgido los
mayores movimientos
antiebolsionados en 2019 más de 100.000
estudiantes se reunieron frente a
nuestra universidad para protestar fue
la primera gran movilización contra
bolsonaro al inicio de la pandemia Así
que creo que siente que es un foro de
resistencia contra él por eso nos ataca
de vuelta tras bloquear más de 500
millones de euros del presupuesto
universitario federal Justo antes de las
elecciones Jair bolsonaro encendió la
llama
ese día miles de estudiantes se
manifestaron en Río una movilización en
las calles y en redes sociales que según
Jessica obligó al gobierno a dar marcha
atrás y congelar el presupuesto Solo
hasta diciembre cuando el pueblo sale a
la calle puede cambiar las cosas cada
vez que nos manifestamos conseguimos que
el Gobierno regule ya sea en la calle o
en redes sociales como Jessica estos
jóvenes estudiantes constituyen uno de
los focos electorales más importantes
para el candidato de izquierdas Lula que
ha prometido dar prioridad a la
educación y al acceso a la universidad
se gana